[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a 5 minutos con como
cada mes tenemos el placer de vivir de
cerca con ustedes la misión de to map es
que a bordo de la estación espacial
internacional en estos seis meses en
órbita alrededor de la tierra los
astronautas de la misión alfa no sólo
realizan experimentos científicos
también operaciones de mantenimiento que
deben llevarse a cabo para que la
estación espacial internacional funcione
correctamente esta ha sido una de las
principales tareas de tomates que en las
últimas semanas la instalación de dos
nuevos paneles solares son plegables y
más potentes que los actuales que ya
empiezan a mostrar sus años de
antigüedad algunos se llevan más de 20
años allá arriba el simple hecho de
ponerse el traje espacial requiere mucho
tiempo y obedece a procedimientos son
muy estrictos una maquinaria compleja
una verdadera nave espacial portátil y
esto es lo que toma pues que quiso
presentarnos este mes aquí está la nueva
entrega de su vídeo diario para france24
a todas y todos hoy me gustaría
presentarles un módulo especial de la
estación espacial internacional es una
esclusa de salida extravehicular
como se llama en inglés es lo que usamos
para prepararnos para hacer las
caminatas espaciales acabamos de hacer
tres en la estación espacial para
instalar nuevos paneles solares y aquí
es donde ocurre la acción siempre
tenemos dos trajes espaciales salimos de
a dos astronautas al mismo tiempo porque
si uno de nosotros tiene un problema el
otro está ahí para ayudarlo y además hay
muchas cosas que son más fáciles de
hacer entre dos personas tres serían
demasiadas una es suficiente dos es la
mejor cantidad aquí tenemos los trajes
espaciales listos
aquí es donde nos vamos a poner se puede
ver que el torso es de metal es bastante
rígido en el pecho que tenemos instalado
un computador con teclas y controles
botones aquí controlamos las
comunicaciones es el sistema de agua el
sistema eléctrico en la ventilación la
personalización uso tenemos una pequeña
pantalla aquí que nos mostrará mensaje
que nos informará el estado de los
sistemas que en su mayoría están en la
parte de la mochila
es donde se encuentra la parte
electrónica y los equipos del traje
espacial que lo hacen una verdadera nave
luego los brazos y las piernas están
hechas de materiales blandos y
completamos el sistema con los guantes
guantes son la única parte realmente
personalizada el traje es adaptable pero
los guantes son realmente personalizados
al astronauta tiene los suyos lo que nos
permite mantener una cierta destreza una
cierta movilidad mientras estamos
presurizados a un tercio de atmósfera de
oxígeno puro afuera es el oasis
y así es como nos preparamos uno de los
componentes más importantes es el casco
tenemos cámaras tenemos un sistema de la
ubicación que nos permite trabajar
las pasamos por el lado iluminado de la
tierra obviamente si estamos expuestos a
una luz demasiado violenta ahí es donde
entra el famoso visor dorado que se
controla aquí al igual que las luces
dentro del traje espacial tenemos un
sistema de enfriamiento por agua que nos
permite mantenernos a una temperatura
adecuada y nos ponemos este traje debajo
se pueden ver los tubos de agua que van
por todo el cuerpo del astronauta
durante una caminata espacial para
protegerlo del exceso de temperatura ya
sea frío o calor
aquí en nuestras casas para caminatas
espaciales tenemos todos nuestro equipo
tenemos todas nuestras cuerdas de
seguridad incluyendo este sistema que
nos permite asegurar cada herramienta no
podemos dejar que una herramienta se nos
escape así que a lo largo de la caminata
espacial
se convierte en algo natural que todo
esté siempre asegura el gran miedo de
los astronautas es dejar que algo se nos
escape y luego detrás de mí finalmente
tenemos la parte que será
despersonalizada aquí tenemos una puerta
de metal una esclusa que baja los
astronautas se hacen aquí detrás de mí
está la última esclusa a la que va a
abrirse una vez que hayamos evacuado el
aire de esa parte de la estación y que
nos permitirá volcar nos de cabeza en el
vacío entonces aquí es donde realmente
comienza la aventura en la estación
espacial y termina cuando volvemos a
entrar después de 7 horas
espacial pasan muchas cosas gracias por
la visita espero que hayan disfrutado de
este pequeño momento conmigo a bordo de
la estación y nos vemos pronto para
otros descubrimientos
no olviden que cada mes toma pesqué nos
entregará detalles de cómo es su día a
día en la estación espacial
internacional y los avances de su misión
y ustedes los podrán conocer sólo aquí
en france 24 los invitamos a seguir con
nuestra programación
[Música]